what up space fam golson here from anime
up we're back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story and wow do we ever have
a legendary historic chapter to cover
today in many ways this chapter is
exactly what we've been waiting for for
a long time so make sure to stay tuned
for this one if you do enjoy these
one-piece videos and want to keep them
coming the best you could do is channel
pyroking within and smash that like
button like it was a giant blue dragon
always remember that smashing his
pirating energy and passing is orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one-piece updates and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on the yonko warlords admirals and much
more linked to that is in the
description and now without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
this chapter is called tenozon turning
point and tenozon pretty much means a
critical advantageous twist and is used
often in games like go and shogi and
since we had the whole go metaphor
running throughout this war it's a
pretty perfect title to use ora himself
acknowledges that this is a critical
chapter so we better pay attention it
starts in the flower capital as people
are partaking in the festival we get a
flashback of how tama couldn't wait and
do nothing and went to help and help she
really did thanks her fruit powers it's
a really touching moment as we see
tenguyama hitetsu hoping and begging for
tama's safety it's interesting how these
characters who wear masks can sometimes
bring on the feels i'm thinking about
sakonji from demon slayer as well and we
get some great panels from oda as we see
a little dark shape from the festival
and oda zooms in to reveal its kaido's
flying castle pretty much already
visible from the capital already
especially if the clouds weren't there
to block it we rejoined the two dragons
momo in kaido we're also told that
master yamato is alone on the roof
injured again crazy to think how many
times she's challenged kaido and yet
again kaido left her alive i'm hoping we
get some more and much needed kaido
characterization soon that will help
shed light on how exactly he views
yamato and her importance to him we see
luffy riding a dragon again and i made a
point out of how hyped that was last
time as well and here we have it being
emphasized verbally as it stated that
the pink dragon is challenging the azure
dragon and is being ridden by straw hat
luffy it's like when the cursed dragon
fused with gaia the fierce knight to
create gaia the dragon champion in other
words for the non-og yu-gi-oh weebs very
hype indeed yamato is still there
putting together all the evidence and
remembering that momo wished he could
turn into a monster like kaido's dragon
form as they keep saying can't wait for
momo to turn into his human or even
hybrid form and for yamato to see the
odin resemblance that reaction of odin's
number one fan will no doubt be
priceless queen quickly realizes that
yamato must have been keeping kaido busy
and that there's no doubt this dragon is
hostile towards them and i just love how
hilarious luffy is here his
conversations with momo are the best
kaido is about to launch his famous
blast breath a yonko's blast breath and
luffy is just like alright momo counter
it with your own breath
oh my god it's so funny momo is just
like there's no way i could do that bro
but to his credit he does appear to
dodge the attack which is honestly just
as good he tells luffy again to remember
that he's in no position to fight right
now remember he's still mentally a kid
and he's facing off against a yonko so
his nervous sweats are totally justified
luffy jumps off the dragon and with an
elephant gun smashes kaido's giant
dragon into the ground i know it usually
leaves no lasting damage on kaido but
visually i just love seeing luffy's tiny
figure by comparison punch around
something as big as kaido's dragon we
then see that luffy randomly asked momo
to bite kaido i love how straightforward
our future pirate king is obviously momo
is hesitant and to himself feels like
there's no way he can do it he does have
some ptsd after all he remembers the
burning castle him screaming out for his
mother kaido lifting his powerless
crying self up and threatening his life
but you know momo is the man so he
pushes through and actually bites hard
into kaido using the memory of when
kaido called his father a fool as
motivation as usual with oda at first it
seems like it might have done some
damage but then kaido calmly looks over
and asks what are you doing brat it's as
if he's responding to an annoying fly
and nothing else momo thinks about how
kaido ruined wano how his parents would
be alive if not for kaido and then the
bite evidently served its purpose as
luffy comes in with another powerful
punch sending kaido flying it makes my
heart smile when luffy says nice going
momo because i know how much those few
words must mean to our future shogun we
then jump to some other fights and they
may not be the main attraction but boy
do they take an interesting turn it
doesn't look good initially for invadash
and nekomamushi it's mentioned that
we've seen the last of the moon tonight
since dragons call forth storm clouds
it's unlikely with two dragons that
it'll show itself again without their
soolong forms jack thinks he will beat
inuarashi and perospero thinks he will
beat nekomamushi it's as good as done in
their opinions jack even says one more
hit and he probably would have been done
pero sparrow similarly knows how lucky
he is about the moon and simply says
nekomamushi will lose because of his bad
luck as nekomamushi and inuarashi look
like they're on the verge of utter
defeat we jump back to luffy who
proclaims that momo just bit one of the
four emperors and asks after doing that
does anything in the world still seem
scary to you i absolutely love this pep
talk and yeah knowing you bit the
strongest creature in the world and live
to tell about it is a pretty cool
motivational boost and definitely a fun
story to tell at parties momo finally
spits out no aka is not scared of
anything and i love seeing yamato's
shining face and expression as she's
witnessing this you can tell that morale
is super high for our side right now
luffy then sends momo to fly and stop
onygashima from landing on the capital
we predicted this would be the case but
loved the way luffy gave him the
confidence to do it and it's the perfect
job for a would-be protector of wano
more importantly it's a job only he
could do right now and he's going to do
it zorro and sanji overheard and are
shocked at the idea that that dragon is
momo even though they get a small moment
in this chapter still great to see zorro
and sanji back to back conversing as
they take on kaido's two strongest
fighters absolutely love it we get luffy
acting epic as luffy does and he stares
down the dragon proclaiming again that
he will definitely beat kaido you gotta
give it to him luffy is one persistent
mofo between momo and luffy the forces
are in an uproar gaining a huge morale
boost these two are definitely leaders
to be able to bring about this kind of
reaction big mom is being big mom and
just laughs at how rambunctious luffy is
being even calling him a brat still
looking forward to the moment where she
stops laughing and starts taking luffy
seriously i also loved kids reaction he
initially also spoke of taking down
kaido but he's pretty much made his
peace with the fact that he won't be the
one to do it and tells luffy you better
be kaido it's a beautiful reaction while
law simply wonders where luffy has been
all this time we see nami tama frankie
and others celebrating luffy's arrival
and encouraging him to go get kaido
kaido is not just playing around anymore
and even turns into his hybrid form
again he asks if luffy really thinks he
has a chance against the yonko the
so-called strongest creature in the
world and luffy says as long as i'm
breathing anything can happen i love
that so much luffy bringing this kind of
attitude to life and the challenges that
present themselves to him are exactly
what one piece is about and then it
happens the clashing of two conkers
hockey users happens and the sky splits
overhead the heavens have split it has
happened as you probably know this has
happened with shanks and whitebeard in
the past and with kaido and big mom it's
pretty much a characteristic of two
yonko clashing at this point and even
though luffy has been called the fifth
emperor because of his feats he never
had this kind of sky-splitting moment to
show his power was up to snuff but now
there is no doubt about it luffy is
officially an emperor or at least
emperor level that's pretty much what
oda is telling us here with this panel
he is fighting with kaido as an equal
now and it's so hyped to be here this is
the turning point that the title is
referring to a historical moment for all
of us one piece fans the heavens have
split and because of that split the moon
has been revealed the shock of jack and
pero sparrow sulong neko and inu use
odin one sword style to cut them down i
love how nekomamushi even mentions you
were saying something about luck to
perospero it's almost like a
reaffirmation that luffy doesn't wait to
be lucky he makes his own luck by never
giving up and we're told by the narrator
so it's official big mom's eldest son
and jack and all star have been defeated
so anyone who talked down on the
scabbards i think this shows just how
useful they can be yeah they didn't beat
kaido but i don't think anyone expected
that but taking down an all-star is
nothing to sneeze at the turning point
started with luffy and then these
victories made it even more pronounced
it's possible because of the title of
this chapter that this critical turn
will lead to a more or less straight
path to victory for our side it's like
they were riding to the top of a cliff
and the rest is downhill with gravity on
their side obviously i don't think it'll
ever be too straightforward against the
yonko let alone the strongest creature
in the world but things definitely look
amazing right now for our side finally
we also see orochi and this shouldn't be
a surprise because i mentioned that with
his power he could still very well be
alive and i'm hoping momo gets to be the
one to finish him off but we'll see the
cowardly mythical zone user is shocked
that jack is defeated but there
remembers it's not his problem after all
everyone is his enemy now which seems
rather fitting for such a shady dude and
that is it the end of this epic chapter
mvp has to go to luffy for me my boy is
officially yonko level and that's only
the beginning he's planning to beat
kaido not just tie with him the end of
this war is definitely getting near if
we believe the title and this really is
the critical point where the rest of the
dominoes will start falling into place
as always let me know your thoughts on
this chapter and what you most look
forward to happening next if you did
enjoy this chapter review and want to
keep them coming you know what to do
channel the pirate king within and smash
that like button with no mercy smash it
like it was a giant blue dragon always
remember that smashing his pirating
energy and passing his orochi energy so
choose wisely if you haven't make this
the video you subscribe and this is
crucial hit that notification bell to
turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one piece updates and you
can bet moving forward the chapters will
be straight fire just like this one and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on all the yonko warlords admirals and
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you